marc un nouveau missile élection
partielle
les socialistes se détend le jura 23e
cantons suisses augmentation de la
criminalité
une enquête sur deux a boudé
mais messieurs bonsoir la france aura
dans sept ans un sixième sous-marin
nucléaire sa construction sera lancé dès
l'année prochaine
ainsi en a décidé ce matin le président
de la république est cependant cela aux
yeux d'une grande partie de la marine et
d'un certain nombre de députés qui avait
émis quelques critiques à ce propos lors
du débat budgétaire sur la défense à
l'automne dernier après donc le
redoutable ferry bhl foudroyant et
autres bâtiments aux noms
impressionnants l'armée française aura
donc en 1985 un sixième sous-marin
atomique avec l'inflexible quelque peu
différent de la génération de l'après
c'est le principe de la dissuasion
atomique ce de montrer sa force à
l'adversaire pour ne jamais avoir à s'en
servir
encore faut-il que la force montrer
paraissent efficace pour que la
dissuasion soit crédible
la force stratégique française comporte
d'abord les missiles du plateau d'albion
porter 3000 km à partir d'un point fixe
c'est très limité de ne dissuade ont
finalement que nos voisins avec les
mirage iii et iv un ravitaillement en
vol
la portée de nos bombes atomiques est un
peu augmenté mais pas de beaucoup
reste les sous marins atomiques
naviguant à grande profondeur ils sont
pratiquement indétectables surtout s'ils
se maintiennent sous l'eau plusieurs
semaines ils peuvent se rapprocher des
côtes ennemis du coup tous les objectifs
deviennent accessibles à leurs missiles
si ceux ci ont une portée assez grand
ces missiles français sont aujourd'hui
les m1 et m2 de 3000 km de portée depuis
le sous-marin en plongée
il équipe les quatre premiers
sous-marins atomiques le redoutable le
terrible le foudroyant et l'indomptable
dans un an ou deux le cinquième sous
marin nucléaire le tenant aura des
missiles plus perfectionné les m20 à
deux étages
le sixième sous-marin dans la
construction était décidée ce matin sera
équipé lui de m4 à trois étages porter
4000 km et surtout chaque missile aim
quatre aura plusieurs bombes atomiques
capable d'atteindre séparément et avec
précision des objectifs différents
le président de la république a donc
approuvé le lancement au début de 1979
d'un sous marin nucléaire lanceur
d'engins d'une nouvelle génération
il sera doté d'un nouveau système
d'armes et il sera directement conçu
pour recevoir les nouvelles armes m 4
lorsqu'elle entrera en service en 1985
il sera construit à l'arsenal de
cherbourg
les sous marins actuels seront
transformés ultérieurement entre 1986 et
1991 pour être adapté au même système
d'armes pas donc une décision patrick
lecocq qui apporte à la fois une réponse
politique et technique à tous ceux qui
depuis quatre ans interrogés sur la
crédibilité de la fourniture et en
français ils ont commencé par la réponse
technique actuellement et georges
leclercq ainsi que le ministre ne vous
rappelez à l'instant les cinq sous
marins nucléaires lanceurs d'engins qui
sont en service ou en construction comme
le temps en sont ou seront dotés d'un
missile qu'on pourra plus un missile de
l'actuelle génération le nouveau
sous-marin l'inflexible donc qui sera
terminée lui en 1985 sera équipé
directement d'un nouveau missiles à
têtes multiples le m4 qui sera alors et
alors seulement en 1984 opérationnel il
n'aura donc pas à subir de refonte pour
s'adapter à ce nouveau missile comme
cela aurait été le cas s'il avait été
lancée en 1975 il ya donc trois ans est
terminée en 1980 dans trois ans à
l'époque a dit steve la décision parlons
de construction vous en souvenez avaient
été prises et puis elle avait été
annulée
peu après l'arrivée à l'elysée du
président giscard d'estaing expliquer
ces trois ans de retard on peut les
expliquer en parlant chiffres un sous
marin nucléaire foot 2 milliards de
francs de francs de 1978 bien sûr le
refondre c'est à dire le modifier pour
l'adapter un nouveau système d'arbre
coûte un milliard à peu près c'est à
dire la moitié du prix d'un sous marin
monsieur bourges estime que l'on a bien
fait donc d'attendre trois ans puisque
c'est
trois années vont nous faire économiser
d'une part un milliard de francs et en
plus vont nous donner un sous-marin plus
ultra valeur deuxième réponse d'ian nous
impose positif et on le voit le rpr vous
le savez notamment rpr monsieur debré et
messmer deux anciens premiers ministres
deux anciens ministres de la défense
nationale également le rpr s'est
toujours montré très favorable à la
notion de force de frappe ne pas
construire de sixième sous-marin
nucléaire lanceur d'engins lui semble
démontrer un affaiblissement en sérieux
de la volonté de dissuasion du chef de
l'état et du gouvernement
alors l'annoncé de la mise en
construction de ce sixième sous-marin
nucléaire lanceur d'engins vous avez
donné son nom l'inflexible prouve le
contraire cela apportera des apaisements
au moins au rpr à la veille bien sûr de
l'examen du budget de la défense
puisque nous parlons de vision d'avenir
sachez que le gouvernement va se réunir
prochainement pour donner une suite au
rapport n'aura sur l'informatique
plus précisément sur ce que le journal
les échos appel ce matin la guerre des
mondes c'est à dire la rencontre de
l'informatique et des télécommunications
vous savez que ce soir à 21h30 jean
pierre elkabbach animera un débat autour
de simon nora simon aura interrogé par
deux journalistes jean daniel pour le
nouvel observateur et aux lilas
chevrillon pour le point et puis quatre
hommes politiques
michel pinton udf alain devaquet repères
laurent fabius parti socialiste et
anicet le pors parti communiste tout
cela donc à 21h30 dans questions voilà
qui nous amène à la politique pure est
d'abord bien sûr à la leçon que tous les
états majors tire aujourd'hui des deux
élections partielles d'hier le deuxième
tour de nom de lancer un deuxième tour
en forme de désaveu très cinglant pour
le député sortant jean-jacques
servan-schreiber nettement battu par le
socialiste yves entendons et puis
premier tour à paris dans le 14e
arrondissement là aussi le candidat la
majorité crie somme la malène a du mal à
résister à la poussée socialiste il aura
encore plus de mal dimanche prochain
d'abord les chiffres bruts nancy 2e tour
abstention 32%
ils vont donc ps 58 et demi pour cent
jean-jacques servan-schreiber udf 41 ans
et demi pour cent paris 1er tour
abstention 47%
christian de la malène rpr 39%
edwige avice
ps 33 % rolande perlic en pc 19%
le reste des voix se partage entre les
douze autres candidats parmi eux
l'écologiste henri fabre luce 3% bien
avec vous n'allez pas il faut commenter
ces résultats
les grandes tendances et ensemble de
considérations générales d'abord où il
valait les grandes tendances vous
l'avait déjà signalé tout à l'heure et
ça sort des résultats eux-mêmes donc un
très net recul de la majorité au cours
de ses diverses élections partielles de
l'été un recul également du parti
communiste et puis une très forte
poussée du parti socialiste alors je
sais pour chaque élection partielle qui
sont toujours des cas particuliers par
définition on peut toujours trouver des
explications personnelles ou des
explications locale mais là il ya en
cette fin d'été un phénomène de
répétition qui souligne bien c'est
tendance et d'où l'on peut tirer quand
même des conclusions politiques
et puis on dit souvent aussi que les
élections partielles sont plus
favorables à l'opposition qu'à la
majorité de même que l'on tic les hommes
préfèrent les blondes mais épousent les
brunes
elle vient les français seraient tentés
partiellement de préférer l'opposition
mais globalement serait fidèle à la
majorité
et il est vrai qu'il ya eu pas mal de
cas dans le passé de ses incartades et
il ya eu l'élection de michel rocard en
l'élection de jean jacques servan
shreiber quelle époque était dans
l'opposition 1970 et puis en 1974 une
série d'élections partielles
on n'avait vu tomber des anciens
ministres comme monsieur le cas et comme
monsieur fontanel jamais mais il me
semble que cette fois ci le mouvement
une ampleur beaucoup plus importante que
dans le passé alors détaillons les
leçons qu'il nous apporte d'abord pour
le gouvernement bien pour le
gouvernement il faut bien dire que ces
élections manifeste l'inquiétude devant
le chômage les manifestes le
mécontentement devant la succession et
la politique économique
monsieur bart a dit très clairement
qu'il ne changerait pas de politique
mais se pose un autre problème
ne faut-il pas expliqué davantage cette
politique c'est ce que commencent à dire
à ses eaux un certain nombre de
parlementaires et cet après midi devant
les parlementaires de l'udf frais liés à
toulon monsieur bart un peu ironisé sur
ce sujet en disant que si le
gouvernement ne s'expliquait pas d'assez
eh bien c'était précisément aux
parlementaires de la majorité à pallier
cette carence
alors on va revenir là dessus
d'abord aussi les leçons pour la
majorité mais la majorité c'est elle
dont qui subit le choc et même mes six
années passées ici ce ne sont pas ses
divisions qui ont causé son recul après
tout l'opposition est bien davantage
divisé elle doit certainement repenser
les rapports entre les partis qui la
composent et les rapports entre ces
partis et le gouvernement
et voilà que pour une fois la leçon
départ bonne pour le parti communiste
elle même et bien oui la leçon est assez
sévère il a pu garder le siège de madame
gutmann en seine-saint-denis en début
d'été mais il accuse un très net recul
partout ailleurs et si dans paris ce
recul n'est pas très sensible le parti
communiste est quand même très nettement
distancés par le parti socialiste
maurice directeur de l'ecal que quelques
rues du caire les 500 voix d'écart au
mois de mars est maintenant c'est de
l'ordre de plusieurs milliers et je
crois que le problème est très difficile
pour le parti communiste
lorsque au début l'union s'est révélé
favorable au parc électoralement
favorables au parti socialiste et le
parti communiste l'a découvert à
l'occasion d'élections partielles en
1974 il a durci sa position
la rupture de la gauche stoppez
peut-être la montée du parti socialiste
on l'a vu au mois de mars
mais maintenant elle paraît à nouveau
être très bénéfique pour le parti
socialiste en parlant justement du
parisien alors le parti socialiste lui
passer le vanni le cier de ces de ces
différentes élections on peut dire
globalement que ces candidats soit au
premier soit deuxième tour font des
bonds de l'ordre de 10% de l'électorat
et cela se produit au moment où après la
défaite électorale du mois de mars
dernier
le parti socialiste est en crise il y à
une dispute sur la stratégie il y as
rivalité entre les personnes alors la
question maintenant est de savoir
comment ses succès vont peser sur ce
débat est sûr c'est que rennes enfin que
nous arrêtions quelques secondes encore
sur le cas particulier l'élection
lorraine car il ya là deux phénomènes
outre toutes les considérations
politiques que l'on voudra d'abord
l'accession au palais-bourbon d'un
nouveau type de socialistes y vendons un
ouvrier
et puis la chute d'une idole on verra
bien si jean-jacques servan-schreiber se
relèvera de ce faux pas après tout il en
a connu d'autres mais il s'agit pour lui
d'un accident assez sévère dans une
carrière politique
mené jusque là tambour battre berlin
président
54 ans est polytechnicien ce lorrain
d'adoption devient député de nancy en 70
journaliste jean-jacques
servan-schreiber créé l'express en 53 et
ans quitte la présidence 25 ans plus
tard après le défi américain un
best-seller il écrit le manifeste
radical répertoire des réformes qu'il
juge utile pour la france
à 47 ans il est président du parti
radical et fonde peu après le mouvement
des réformateurs avec jean lecanuet
ministre des réformes pendant 13 jours
dans le gouvernement de jacques chirac
jjss plutôt débordant d'activité et
d'idées par le souvent des problèmes de
tous d'une façon originale
si nous ne réagissons pas avec des
moyens d'exception pour empêcher cette
affreuse marée noire et chômage de
continuer à monter je n'ai pas d'autres
commentaires à faire
et si ce christ entendu il aura servi ce
soir
la lorraine et le pays 56 ans marié père
de deux enfants ce lorrain de pure
souche a commencé à travailler dès l'âge
de 14 ans à pont-à-mousson la ville
qu'il n'a jamais quittée et dont il est
conseiller municipal depuis than ils
vont tous dont est ouvrier au p3o
fonderie de pont-à-mousson sa carrière
de militant commence à la joc la
jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne il adhéra
la cftc puis à la cfdt
à 44 ans il devient secrétaire du comité
d'entreprise à la société qui l'emploie
ils vont tous inscrits au parti
socialiste en 1973
trois ans après il devient conseiller
général de meurthe et moselle
plutôt timide cet enfant du cru parle
comme tout le monde
des problèmes de tout le monde
aujourd'hui plus long blanc coeur et
bien sont ceux qui ont voulu exprimer
le désaveu de la politique menée par le
gouvernement de monsieur bart il affirme
ainsi un désir profond d'aller vers un
changement de politique
une politique qui donnerait à chacun de
droit au travail
une politique qui donnerait le droit à
la concertation et à la réduction des
inégalités
witt évident que l'élection de monsieur
tondon dépasse largement les murs de
nancy la circonscription tous les hommes
politiques sont pencher avec attention
sur les chiffres a commencé d'abord par
le premier ministre qui ne semble
pourtant pas vouloir en tirer des
conclusions nationales telles élections
partielles dit il n'exprime pas le
sentiment général de france dans
l'écouté interviewé par daniel brel qui
mécontentement je dirais que cela est
certain est que cela est compréhensible
car les difficultés auxquelles la france
a à faire face aux difficultés qui
affectent les français et je comprends
très bien que hills et une certaine
mauvaise humeur mais vous savez que les
vagues de la mauvaise humeur qu'on règle
les problèmes et les français sont assez
plein de bon sens pour ne pas se
comporter lorsqu'il s'agit d'élections
générales
indépendamment de leurs dons leur
croyance profond on en une société de
liberté et donc le régime de la 5ème
république tel qu'il fonctionne c'est à
toulon que raymond barre répondait aux
questions de danièle breem plus
précisément à ollioules où il assistait
à l'ouverture des journées
parlementaires de l'udf journée qui
doivent durer quatre jours et qui seront
présidés de bout en bout par roger
chinaud vous allez lui jean le calvez et
d'où nous rendrons compte dans nos
prochaines éditions à commencer par
celle de 23h vraiment bar qui est son
arrivée à toulon avait été accueilli par
quelques manifestations et la voiture du
président udf jean le calvez a même été
endommagé par l'une d'elles le pare
brise de son véhicule a volé en éclats
sur le cac ne l'a pas été molestés mais
son chauffeur a été légèrement blessé à
la main et c'est peut-être pour répondre
à toutes ces manifestations que raymond
barre a été très dur
dans son discours devant les
parlementaires de l'udf vous allez
l'entendre bien que conscient d'une
certaine popularité
le premier ministre ne veut pas reculer
d'un pouce aux hivernales contestation
par les adverbes coup de semonce des
élections partielles avec des
abstentions de 40% chausse trappes et
rila en plus qu'à ne m'impressionne pas
maintenant plus qu ils m'ont
impressionné
nagl ceux qui voient dans mon attitude
une obstination mellul suffisance se
trompe totalement c'est l'avenir de la
france et des français qui est en jeu
vous parlez de ces manifestations toulon
manifestations d'ouvriers de plusieurs
secteurs de la construction navale dans
terrain puis parallèlement aujourd'hui
en lorraine d'autres manifestations mais
cette fois pour protester contre le
nouveau plan acier annoncées par le
gouvernement
manifestations grèves et puis blocage
des autoroutes lorraine près de metz
tout cela donc en images
à commencer donc par les manifestations
de lorraine puis celle de toulon
et c'est dans les usines du groupe
sacilor cela que la grève était le plus
suivi 70 à 90% de grévistes selon le
syndicat 40% selon la direction par
contre dans les autres sociétés de la
sidérurgie lorraine
la participation fut nettement plus
faibles 6% à 9 maisons et pont-à-mousson
10 à 15% à jean louis en début de
matinée plusieurs centaines d'ouvriers
ont bloqué l'autoroute mais survivent
provoquant d'importants embouteillages
mais sans qu'aucun incident n'était
signalé
manifestations également à toulon alors
que monsieur raymond barre se rendait
aux journées organisées par le dr six à
dix mille manifestants des chantiers
navals ont dû fuir la ville et l'autre
manifestants auxquels l'accès au centre
chaque ballon s'en prenant à la voiture
de monsieur de cannes où une délégation
intersyndicale fut reçu par monsieur
roger chinaud qu'il assurera que l'udf
soumettrait au gouvernement des
propositions précises pour maintenir
l'emploi dans les secteurs concernés
mg on nous signale qu'il ya eu quelques
petits problèmes de son bon je vous prie
de m'excuser si une dernière minute pour
les cookies harlin le président de la
république s'est rendu cet après midi à
clermont ferrand à l'hôpital de clermont
ferrand au chevet de son père monsieur
edmond giscard d'estaing je vous
rappelle que monsieur edmond giscard
d'estaing âgé de 84 ans était
hospitalisée à split alizés pardon à la
suite d'un malaise cardiaque il y a
quelques jours
et voilà donc le président de la
république s'est rendu à son chevet de
cet après midi a clairement faire le
présent la république qui avait reçu
aujourd'hui à l'élysée didier ratsiraka
qui est le président de la république
malgache en voyage officiel pour trois
autres visiteurs ce matin chez valéry
giscard d'estaing une cinquantaine de
maires polynésiens à qui le chef de
l'état a confirmé un voyage de sa part
en polynésie au printemps prochain
le proche orient maintenant après yasser
arafat et le col et le cradat si c'est
le président syrien hafez el-assad qui
va rendre visite demain au roi hussein
de jordanie
officiellement ils viennent lui rendre
compte des résultats du sommet de damas
est à dire du sommet des pays du front
la fermeté il vient de s'achever et puis
pendant ce temps à jérusalem la knesset
se réunissaient pour commencer à
examiner les clauses de l'accord le camp
david
à commencer par la décision d'évacuer
les informations israéliennes dans le
sinaï menahem begin a ouvert le débat
avec l'assurance d'un homme qui sait que
la partie est gagnée pour béguines en
effet la corde camp david est un accord
honorable et israël devaient l'accepter
le premier israélien a mis au pied du
mur les opposants au sein de son parti
en leur demandant de changer d'attitude
ou de démissionner le premier israélien
est sûr de remporter une large majorité
lors du vote de mercredi
l'opposition travailliste elles mêmes
dunks elle critique le démantèlement des
points de peuplement voter oui
attendent pas ce matin au pays basque
espagnol deux gardes civils ont été
abattu d'une rafale de mitraillette
devant une soixantaine de témoins au
marché municipal de san sebastien aux
états unis encore un grave accident
l'avion un boeing 727 aurait percuté un
petit monomoteur pardon à une dizaine de
kilomètres de l'aéroport de san diego à
bord du boeing
135 personnes il n'y aurait pas de
survivants me disent les gagnants des
puces les détails peut-être dans le
cours de ce journal ou en tout cas à 23
heures les petits suisses du jura ne
sont pas allés en classe aujourd'hui ils
avaient jours fériés
la suisse compte en effet depuis hier un
canton de plus le jure victoire
écrasante pour les francophones du jura
suisse par près de 83%
les électeurs de toute la suisse compte
approuver la création de ce 23e temps
citoyen victoire
vingt-deux cantons et ce aujourd'hui 23
cantons contre 0
et 82 % contre 18 nous ont accepté dans
l'alliance fédéral une république eni
soixante sept mille habitants dont plus
du tiers a moins de 20 ans devient ainsi
libres de choisir leur enseignement leur
justice leur police leurs impôts en
suisse toutes les formations politiques
importantes ainsi que des églises
approuvait cette indépendance qui met
fin à une très ancienne décision celle
du congrès de vienne qui rattachait en
1815 les sept districts du jura suisse à
berne à l'écart des grands axes routiers
couvrant 8 137 kilomètres carrés cette
république jurassienne veut favoriser
une illustration de la langue française
et déclare dans l'article 1er de la
constitution être un état démocratique
et sociale fondée sur la fraternité
la convention européenne des droits de
l'homme signée par la suisse et à
laquelle se réfère expressément la
constitution jurassienne stipule que
tout individu doit pouvoir exprimer ses
pensées je cite sans sidération de
frontières
si aujourd'hui c'est un référendum qui
consacre la naissance d'un canton il est
juste de reconnaître que depuis près de
30 ans les mouvements autonomistes
revendiquait par divers moyens humains
semblables comme ici à moutier où les
manifestations donné lieu il ya peu de
moi encore à des affrontements violents
paradoxe cette ville de moutier restera
attaché au canton de berne
les autonomistes jurassiens n'ont donc
pas l'intention de désarmer
pour l'heure cependant c'est la fête la
population catholique en très grande
majorité a salué avec joie le verdict
électoral
plus de la moitié des suisses ne sont
pas allés voter hier les autres en
concédant la création de cet état
voulait peut-être montré qu'il savait
aussi bousculé leurs traditions
voilà états unis maintenant team et
carter viennent profiter de son succès
diplomatique
à quand des vies pour faire voter un
nombre de réformes par le concret parmi
ces réformes sont plaints énergie son
plan qu'ils voient qu'ils voyaient
jusqu'à lors sans cesse repoussée un des
points essentiels de ce plan c'est la
récupération des gaz naturel une sorte
de technique que les français maîtrisent
assez bien mais qui me pose encore gérer
voire beaucoup de progrès crédibles mais
les pétroliers sont paradoxalement les
plus gros fournisseurs d'énergie mais
aussi les plus gros gaspillage à terre
ou en mer quand on extrait du pétrole
on voit toujours ses énormes torchères
qui brûlent mais il faut savoir que avec
ou dans le pétrole il y a toujours du
gaz et c'est ce gaz là qu'on brûle on
estime à 10 ans de la consommation
mondiale d'énergie tout ce qui est parti
en fumée sur les champs de pétrole
ce n'est pourtant pas faute d'avoir
essayé de l'utiliser au point de vue
technique on ne maîtrise la technique du
gaz naturel liquéfié que depuis un peu
plus d'une dizaine d'années
c'est donc une technique toute récente
et en ce qui concerne l'économie
c'est avant tout une question de
distance le le coût de transport du gaz
est à peu près cinq fois plus élevé que
le coût de transport du pétrole
pour transporter ce gaz il faut donc
d'abord le transformer et c'est ce que
l'on fait ici dans l'île d'audace au
large d'abu dhabi il ne faut pas oublier
que le gaz est une énergie très diffus
en effet pour avoir l'équivalent
énergétique d'une tonne de pétrole
il faut 1000 mètres cubes de gains pour
diminuer son volume on leur en liquide
soit en le compressant soit en le
refroidissant
la plus grosse partie de ce gaz fatale
c'est à dire le gaz toujours associé au
pétrole est constitué de meta mais pour
le liquéfier il faut abaisser cette
température à moins 160 degrés on y
arrive
grâce à des tours de refroidissement qui
sont l'équivalent de 10 millions de
réfrigérateurs domestiques
la compagnie française des pétroles qui
a beaucoup investi dans cette forme de
récupération d'énergie n'est pourtant
pas très optimiste pense pas qu'on
puisse espérer du gaz libération de nos
problèmes une solution de nos problèmes
mais on peut espérer en réseau une part
limitée mais pas négligeable et avec
l'avantagé d'une contrepartie financière
qui pourraient être substantiels si
l'industrie française se montre capable
d'exporter les techniques et les
services requis pour ces projets je ne
crois pas être pessimiste simplement il
faut être réaliste et voir que les
quantités disponibles ne sont pas à la
mesure des besoins énergétiques pour la
fin de ce siècle
donc le gaz ne peut être qu'un appoint
une solution partielle aux problèmes que
nous avons à faire ça mais ne peut
certainement pas à lui tout seul venir
combler le déficit énergétique
prévisible
si la france se place tout premier rang
pour la technologie de la liquéfaction
du gaz naturel
les avis sont partagés quant à son
développement pour notre
approvisionnement énergétique
la production de ce gaz de pétrole d'ici
à 1981 sera de 16 % de nos besoins
énergétiques et ce chiffre ne sera
peut-être jamais dépassé même si on
récupère tout le gaz au lieu de le
brûler dans les torchères du monde
entier
la criminalité en hausse l'augmentation
pour 77 atteint les 15% ce qui est beau
mais ce qu'ils méritent aussi d'être
nuancée car nous savons bien en matière
de criminalité il y as délinquance et
délinquance pour le faire en effet
personne n'aurait imaginé espérait que
la criminalité puisse diminuer depuis la
nuit des temps elle fait partie
intégrante de la vie des hommes allaient
d'ailleurs eu malheureusement l'une des
caractéristiques fondamentales alors 15
% d'augmentation
et cette croissance sérieuse n'a aucune
raison de stopper en 78 surtout une
augmentation de 18% la notte de la
grande criminalité
vous savez peut-être pas patrick que les
policiers font trois grandes
distinctions entre les crimes et les
délits la grande criminalité homicide
avec violence rapt torture prise d'otage
s'était fiancé terra la moyenne
criminalité cambriolages délinquance
fiscale viole atteintes aux biens etc en
augmentation de 12%
enfin la délinquance c'est à dire tout
le reste en augmentation de 16% et tout
ceci vous inspire un temps d'observation
pas vu la première observation si la
criminalité de profits augmentent en
revanche la criminalité de comportement
ne bouge pas en clair ça signifie que
les français s'ils se laissent tenter
par l'appât du gain de l'argent et cela
correspond aux curieusement d'ailleurs
aux années de croissance économique ne
cède pas à la violence pour le plaisir
de la violence en somme si nous
permettait on tue pour l'argent mais pas
pour le plaisir
deuxième observation la france reste par
rapport à beaucoup d'autres pays une
nation calme relativement calme plus
calme en tout cas par exemple que la
suède l'italie ou l'espagne
mais on y vole autant qu'en allemagne
dernier point l'étude prouve que 38 %
seulement des enquêtes aboutissent
même pas une sur deux comme les
policiers français ne sont pas plus
idiot que les autres au contraire ce
pourcentage révèlent leur manque de tout
le temps et surtout leur manque de
moyens
ce pourtant ce pourcentage une réussite
sur deux aussi est l'une des raisons de
la pleurent d'aujourd'hui notre page
culturelle maintenant une drôle de pages
culturelles de l voir la barbe statufié
et oui la barbe est à l'honneur au musée
bourdelle à ce moment à paris quelques
200 pilosité sous forme de peintures de
dessins et surtout de sculptures et ce à
un moment où dans la rue la mode revient
fait aucun homme sur cinq est barbu
qu'elle soit longue et postiches ou bien
en vagues grand p c'est elle qu'on
aperçoit en premier le matin dans sa
glace et pour cette compagne fidèle
il fallait bien le nommage cessé
aujourd'hui les barbus sont au musée de
ramsès ii à napoléon iii de gambetta à
la chine antique 30 siècles d'histoire à
travers une revue des fantaisies
auxquels nos ancêtres célèbres ou
anonymes n'ont cessé de vous et leur
système capillaire ou bill en egypte les
dieux les rois les nobles orner leur
monde ton d'une barbe factice propres à
leur classe le 19e siècle a été lui un
âge d'or pour l'e book plein de morgue
et les moustaches en gros
or musée qu'est ce qui fait porter la
barbe en 1978
le bien est un peu à la mode c'est
combien sont ils ces barrages imagine
20% à peu près qui est important les
jeunes surtout je crois que les jeunes
ont une envie de changer de tête mais
donne sont comme les femmes on a besoin
de changer près qu'on a besoin de faire
une rentrée avec une tête différentes
une barbe doit être toujours impeccable
une dent de deux propres nettoyer
vraiment dire que les cheveux lavés tous
les jours face hérault cologne il ya une
plus affreux qui le bar de talent ah les
femmes aiment bien le seul en poche
c'est toujours le même problème
un récent sondage avait quelque peu
malmené nous dirigeants politiques
c'est peut-être une solution pour
reconquérir leur popularité
et lui comment le préférez vous je n'ai
pas fini alors c'est donc le menton
glabre vous ne voyez que je vous parle
de la météo maintenant faut aujourd'hui
hormis les nuages du côté de la manche
sur le reste de la france est bien le
fameux été indien s'est maintenue demain
la moitié nord du pays sera recouverte
par une zone nuageuse qui l'après-midi
descendra vers le sud en l'alternance
avec de belles éclaircies
les rendez-vous avec la relation
l'antenne de ce soir d'abord un rappel
21h35 question de temps avec le débat
autour de simon aura animé par jean
pierre elkabbach et puis vers 23 heures
gérard holtz vous présentera le dernier
jour merci de votre attention bonne
soirée à tous
à demain